Donald Trump has unleashed another
unhinged attack on Twitter a series of
bizarre and Confused tweets rife with
the bogus capitalization we've become
accustomed to and most importantly
totally baseless allegations the focus
is Robert Muller and Russia and the
investigation I'm going to show you the
tweets it's very clear Trump is nervous
between the mana for trial starting
tomorrow Cohen ready to give it all up
to Robert Muller news that Trump knew
and approved of the Trump Tower meeting
with Russians promising dirt on Hillary
the guy is clearly nervous and yesterday
he unleashed the following tirade about
Robert Muller I won't even mention that
there are 14 improper 13 improper
capitalizations here just just know that
they're there there is no collusion
Trump said the Robert Muller rigged
witch hunt headed but now by 17
increased from 13 including an Obama
White House lawyer angry Democrats was
started by a fraudulent dossier paid for
by crooked Hillary Hemu DNC therefore
the witch-hunt is an illegal scam is
Robert Muller ever going to release his
conflicts of interest with respect to
President Trump
including the fact that we had a very
nasty and contentious business
relationship I turned him down to head
the FBI one day before appointment a
special counsel and Comey
is his close friend also why is Muller
only appointing angry Dems some of whom
have worked for crooked Hillary others
including himself have worked for Obama
and why isn't Muller looking at all of
the criminal activity and real Russian
collusion on the Democrat side
Podesta dossier I'm wondering if there's
anything that's true in that rant 13
random capitalizations but beyond that
Democrats aren't running molars
investigation in fact Republican Moeller
appointed by Republican George W Bush is
running it the dossier wasn't fraudulent
it also wasn't the basis for the
investigation nothing about the probe is
illegal that's been explored
significantly in detail at this point
and the fact that molar was FBI director
for Obama again seems totally irrelevant
since he was appointed not only is he a
Republican he was appointed by
Republican George W Bush and what you've
got to realize is that trumps four tweet
tirade does nothing to attack the merit
or the fat
of what happened or what Cohen knows or
what Trump did and I like how also Trump
says he had a very nasty relationship
with Robert Muller there's this story
Pat that molar angrily left Trump's golf
club like ten years ago
over a dispute over golf club fees
Muller has put out a statement or his
spokesperson has saying he just left the
club there was really no controversy but
in either case that just has nothing to
do with this seem so minor I'm moving
I'm going to a different club I don't
want to support this thing I'm gonna
play golf somewhere else
yeah that's why there's it there is a
so-called witch-hunt that has already
found 32 people to indict if that's the
big blockbuster that makes Muller
personally committed to advance Trump
you're gonna need to come up with
something bigger and this is all the
behavior somebody who's really worried
that the probe is not only not ending
its advancing and it's getting closer
and closer to Trump and to put a final
point on that let's go to White House
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
herself she said back in 2016
quote when you're attacking FBI agents
because you're under criminal
investigation you're losing that seems
to be the most prescient comment about
this entire thing and of course it
wasn't made about Trump at the time but
it certainly seems to apply today send
me your thoughts what do you think is
behind this absolutely unhinged Twitter
tirade that Trump Unleashed I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is sponsored in part by
zip recruiter hiring used to be hard
multiple job sites stacks of resumes a
confusing review process but now hiring
can be easy and you only have to go to
one place to get it done and that is zip
recruiter dot-com slash Pakman zip
recruiter will send your job to over 100
of the web's leading job sites but they
don't stop there they're powerful
matching technology will scan thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and invite them to apply to
your job you don't want to hire the
wrong people it is a huge loss for all
sorts of companies when they make hiring
errors and zip recruiter will analyze
resumes as they come in spotlight the
top can
so you won't miss great matches and zip
recruiters so effective that 80% of
employers get a quality candidate
through the website within the first 24
hours no wonder zip recruiter is the
highest rated hiring site in America and
David Pakman show viewers and listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter
dot-com slash Pakman that is zip
recruiter comm /p a que ma n it's the
smartest way to hire zip recruiter comm
slash Pakman